what if you asked people in AI what if
you were right what have you actually
succeeded in the goals that you have set
for the field and it seemed to me that
almost no one was asking that question
and certainly nobody had an answer and
over though that was in the early 90s
and over the next 20 years or so I
started to think about what kinds of
answers you might have and it became I
would say a little bit more urgent for
me when I saw a big dog which is the
Boston Dynamics the four-legged robot
which we've seen that video where the
one of their engineers tries to push it
over
it basically kicks this robot tries to
push it to the ground with his foot so
he's probably the first to go and you
know and I and it actually you know it
sort of recoils and stumbles and then
gets back on its feet again in such a
lifelike way and I had worked on leg
locomotion in the 90s and it's a hard
problem and you look at that video you
think ok that problem is basically
solved you know what if we solve some of
the other problems the problems of
dexterous manipulation for robots which
is another big open problem in the field
the problem of understanding language
what have we actually nail these
problems and and to some extent we've
now largely nailed the problem of speech
recognition and in some ways although in
very fragile and peculiar ways we solve
the problem of recognition of objects in
visual images and if you've ever used
Google Translate these days machine
translation seems to work incredibly
well so we're starting to nail some of
these problems and so this has made me
think harder and here's the problem that
I see we have what you might call the
standard model so because it has its
standard model and AI has a
model and it's the same standard model
that control theory has but cybernetics
has that statistics has and economics
has operations research is the same
model you create optimizing machinery
for which you specify an objective and
then you hope that you've got the
objective right and so interestingly Sir
John was talking about the book by
Norbert Wiener human use of human beings
and in that book he says the purpose
that we put into the machine has to be
the purpose that we really desire
otherwise we're toast so that's the
standard model this is how we do things
so this is you know a big chunk of 20th
century technology is based on that
model and we know also said that it's
only human impotence
that has protected us from human folly
by which he meant that our machines are
so stupid and they have impacts on such
a small scale but if you put the wrong
purpose in up to now you've been able to
switch them off reset you know hit
yourself on the head you say okay
obviously I forgot you know I forgot
about this how about that so the
question is when machines are more
intelligent than human beings we may not
have that choice open the pod bay doors
hell
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that and even before that so we talked
about social media so rod was were
saying that we are sort of at the mercy
of social media and but look at this
from the point of view of the Machine
right what is the purpose put into the
machine
the purpose is maximize click-through
right feed people stuff that they're
going to click on because that's how we
make money right and you might say well
how do you maximize click-through you
just send people stuff that they like
clicking on right simple as that
actually that's not what the algorithms
are doing that's probably what Facebook
and Google and so on thought that the
algorithms were going to do that the
algorithms would adjust to the people's
preferences but in fact that's not how
reinforcement learning works
reinforcement learning changes the state
of the world to maximize the reward and
the state of the world in this case is
your brain so what does it do it changes
you in a way that makes you more
predictable so that it can then send you
stuff that it knows you're going to
click on and who is more predictable
than a raving fascist or a raving
communist right so the algorithm simply
operate in a straightforward way to push
you know so whichever side of the
spectrum you're on it's gonna push you
to the extreme by feeding you algorithms
that are a little bit to the left or a
little bit to the right of where you
currently are and it does that very
efficiently and creates raving fascists
and raving communists who will then lap
up all of the raving content that that
that the world can produce and there's
there's a whole industry you know that
has grown up simply to feed that process
so that simple algorithm is not very
smart it's a reinforcement learning
algorithm has possibly destroyed the EU
NATO NATO Western democracy and that's
just 50 lines of code right imagine
imagine if it was if it was a really
intelligent system operating